BRADY HARAN: What's your
favorite number, and why?
Please leave a comment under
this video so I can
compare them all.
And in the meantime, here are
the answers given by some of
the top people on YouTube.
Now, I had to interview some
of these people in unusual
locations, like up trees
and in toilets.
So it's a bit of a hodgepodge.
But it's also a bit of fun.
DEREK MULLER: I'm Derek Muller
from Veritasium.
And my favorite number is i--
HANK GREEN: We're in the
toilets at YouTube.
DEREK MULLER: --the square
root of negative 1.
HANK GREEN: I'm Hank Green of
SciShow and also CrashCourse
and Vlogbrothers.
And I'm a big fan
of the number 2.
STEVE SPANGLER: So my name
is Steve Spangler.
MICHAEL STEVENS: I am Michael
from the channel Vsauce.
STEVE SPANGLER: I grew
up in a family of
professional magicians.
MICHAEL STEVENS: My favorite
number is the number 17,
because I love making 7's with
this little guy in the middle,
so that you know it's not a 1.
It's something that my dad
always did, and I just adopted
without ever thinking
about it.
STEVE SPANGLER: Number 13 has
to be my absolute all time
favorite number.
ANGELA LIN: Hi, I'm Angela
from YouTube EDU.
STEVE SPANGLER: If you really
wanted to see a real
magician's magic wand, it's
exactly 13 inches long.
ANGELA LIN: My number is 7.
And I know it's kind of generic,
but when I was really
young, people told me that
it was a lucky number.
MICHAEL STEVENS: 17 was also the
channel of Nickelodeon in
Stillwell, Kansas,
where I grew up.
ANGELA LIN: So then I played
a bunch of sports.
And every single sport that I
played-- volleyball, tennis,
whatever it was--
my number was 7.
BRADY HARAN: Michael from Vsauce
has a little line.
But you--
ANGELA LIN: You know, I
went through a phase--
I went through a phase
where I definitely
drew it with the line.
And then I just decided, you
know what, simpler is better.
ALEX DAINIS: I'm Alex
from BiteSciZed, and
my number is 27.
ANGELA LIN: Every year
on 7/7, on July 7, I
do something special.
So I started it on 7/7/07.
And I remember I went kayaking
that day, because I'd never
been kayaking before.
ALEX DAINIS: As I was growing
up, my favorite number was
actually always my
brother's age.
But when I was 13, I decided
that was silly.
And so the last one stuck.
And so my favorite number
has always stuck at 27.
BRADY HARAN: Oh, you do
one of those things.
ALEX DAINIS: I do.
I do.
BRADY HARAN: Why?
ALEX DAINIS: I don't know.
I think it kind of
distinguishes it.
Sometimes my handwriting
is terrible.
And so my 7's look like 1's.
So I'll toss a little
dash on it.
MICHAEL STEVENS: And 17 is also
significant for another reason.
How come I can't remember it?
It's prime.
What was the other thing?
This is called not
respecting your
favorite number well enough.
DESTIN: I'm Destin.
My number is 21.
It's really hard
to explain why.
MIKE RUGNETTA: My name
is Mike Rugnetta
from PBS Idea Channel.
And my number is 1024.
BRADY HARAN: Hang on, why'd
you-- what's with that?
MIKE RUGNETTA: Zero fill.
It's a compulsion just from
handwriting so many-- my
handwriting is really bad.
CAITLIN HENDRICKSON:
I'm Caitlin
Hendrickson, work at YouTube.
My number is 16.
JOHN GREEN: Hi, I'm John Green
of the Vlogbrothers, and my
favorite number is 37, because
it was the dorm room that I
first lived in when I went
to boarding school.
CAITLIN HENDRICKSON: Growing
up, I wanted to drive.
So 16 in the US is when
you can drive.
BRADY HARAN: Do you do
that with your 7's?
MIKE RUGNETTA: I do.
I do that with my 7's.
And I do my 1's like
this, too.
BRADY HARAN: All right, dude.
1024-- why?
MIKE RUGNETTA: 1024.
It's a very sort of nice, round
number in computing.
Having a degree in computer
science, it has a magical
quality about it, I guess.
ALEX DAINIS: So actually, I
also have a little bit of
synesthesia.
So numbers have colors for me.
So 2 is green, and
7 is yellow.
So 27 is actually a very
greenish yellow number.
DESTIN: You've heard
of synesthesia.
I don't have it, but I
think it's amazing.
To me, there's a certain
sharpnesses for certain numbers.
HENRY REICH: My name's Henry.
I make MinutePhysics videos.
And my favorite number is j.
MICHAEL STEVENS: My first kiss
wasn't until I was 18.
So it was the last full year
I live before I knew
what lips felt like.
CAITLIN HENDRICKSON: And I
always wanted to have a sweet
16 birthday party, which my
parents never gave me.
But I'll make up for that maybe,
when I turn 30 in a
couple of years.
MICHAEL STEVENS: Oh, then the
17th floor is the floor that I
lived on in New York, when
I lived in Brooklyn.
But I almost actually lived on
the 16th floor, because the
building skipped the 13th.
The elevators went right from
11 to 12 to 14, 15, 16, 17.
Boom.
He's been with me my whole
life, basically.
DESTIN: So certain numbers
are sharper than others.
So, like, a 1 would
be kind of sharp.
A 2 is very dull.
But a 3 is very, very high.
They have this sharpness
to them.
I don't know what it is.
So it's like this.
And if I take 3 and 7
and multiply them
together, I get 21.
And for some reason, 21 seems
to be this very bright,
cheerful, proper number.
BRADY HARAN: So how high will 21
be on the sharpness scale.
DESTIN: Oh, it's way up here.
It's like, it's off the page.
PATRICK JONES: Hi,
I'm PatrickJMT.
And my favorite number,
or one of my
favorite numbers, is 1729.
HENRY REICH: Now, before you say
j isn't a number, I mean,
j is a number.
COLIN GREGORY PALMER GREY: I'm
CGPGrey, and my favorite
number is 0.
I like 0 because it's not
an obvious number.
You can have counting
systems--
there's one thing, two things,
three things, four things.
But mathematics existed for a
long time without having a 0
as part of it.
So it's a number, but
it also isn't
anything in and of itself.
VI HART: I'm Vi Hart.
You have to tell me what a
number is if I'm going to
choose one.
All right, I'm having
trouble with this.
HENRY REICH: Similar to the way
i is the square root of
negative 1.
But what it actually means is
that i squared is negative 1.
J squared is plus 1.
But j is not 1.
COLIN GREGORY PALMER GREY: But
one of the other things that I
like about 0 is that it's the
kind of unsung workhorse of
the mathematical world.
You have 0.
And then if you want to make
10, you put a one in
front of that 0.
And now we have 10 things.
And people focus on the 1.
But it's really the 0 that
is doing all the work
to make that a 10.
And then the same thing
with 100 or 100,000.
We keep adding 0's.
We keep adding nothing,
but making the
numbers much, much larger.
VI HART: Students in school
are like, oh, what's i?
That's not really a number.
And then there's j.
j's a good one.
It's already taken.
BRADY HARAN: You know that
Derek-- you can see on there
that Derek chose i.
You chose j.
What's the difference?
Why'd you pick that one?
HENRY REICH: Who wants to pick
the team that's going to win
all the time?
Who wants to pick the New
York Yankees, you know?
You want to pick the underdog.
You don't want to pick what
everyone else has
already gone for.
VI HART: Star, which
is not a number.
It's like a number.
The thing is it's smaller than
all the positive numbers, and
it's larger than all the
negative numbers,
but it's not 0.
It gets confused with the 0.
This is one of those weird
things you get in
combinatorial game theory.
And I like it.
I think the very not-numberness
of it, I think
that's what appeals about a lot
of these numbers to us,
like the weirdness of j,
the weirdness of i, the
weirdness of 0.
COLIN GREGORY PALMER GREY: I
like 0's non-obviousness and
its incredible usefulness.
BRADY HARAN: Does j exist?
HENRY REICH: Does j exist?
I mean, does any number exist?
-So what we're going to be
talking about today is whether
or not numbers exist.
We're going to be thinking about
three different schools
of thought on this.
BRADY HARAN: Don't forget to
leave your favorite number and
the reason under the video.
And if you're wondering what
I'm going to do with this,
well, I don't exactly
know yet.
But when I decide, I'll probably
let you know via the
numberphile Facebook
and Twitter.
So make sure you're following
us on there.